apple's brand new 14 inch m1 pro macbook
pro now comes with a double bend chip
and what i mean by that is that both the
cpu and the gpu are bin so you only get
eight cores instead of 10 on the unbind
bottle and 14 gpu cores instead of 16.
so to go from the bin model to the
completely unbend full m1 pro chip it
costs 300
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
run a ton of different tests we've got
benchmarks we've got real world stuff
photo editing video editing programming
logic pro music production to find out
if it's actually worth spending the
extra 300 bucks for the unbanned ship or
if you just grab the base model and be
fine so without further ado let's get
right into it first things first we've
got the standard geekbench 5 benchmark
open right here and as you can see we
have 16 gigs of ram on both of these now
if you're interested in seeing if it's
worth upgrading to 32 max is actually
going to do a video with 16 versus 32
with the m1 pro chip and he's going to
be testing a bunch of different stuff
including a ram stress test to see if
it's worth spending the extra 400 or not
but without further ado let's go ahead
and run the cpu benchmark and while this
test is running i do want to mention our
giveaway yes we are giving away a 2500
macbook pro it's actually this one right
here the 14 inch with a one terabyte ssd
all you got to do is make sure you're
subscribed to our channel and leave a
comment below on any of our launch week
videos what we're going to do is choose
one of those videos at random and choose
a random comment and we're gonna ship it
to you no matter where you are in the
world no matter what kind of taxes there
are import taxes we are shipping it to
you so be sure to subscribe and comment
right now all right the test is finished
and we are pretty much getting expected
results going from eight cores to 10
cores which is 25 percent more cores
we're actually getting 27
better multi-core performance and the
single core is actually staying
basically the same because they are
using the same performance cores so so
far that's actually a pretty good
improvement for the 200
and now let's go ahead and move over to
the graphics side and run geekbench 5's
metal graphics test and there we go we
have our score 39687
on the unbinned version and 34736
that is a difference of 14
faster and it actually lines up because
it has 15 percent more gpu cores going
from 14 to 16. so with that said let's
go ahead and do a different test let's
get into gfx bench which is a gaming
test and here we go we have the standard
1440p aztec ruins high tier tests let's
begin all right we have our scores and
this is interesting we have
165.5 fps on the unbend higher end model
and 147.3
on the 14 core bin model that is only
12.3
faster so it looks like we're not
getting i guess as big of an improvement
in this test compared to geekbench 5 so
i think i'm going to test just one more
gaming benchmark and here we have
wildlife extreme we're doing the
unlimited mode test to basically stress
them out as much as possible so let's
start there you go the test is finished
and it looks like we're getting the same
results 12.4 percent more fps 62.4
compared to
55.5 so in reality for all the gamers
out there is it worth spending 300
dollars to get the unbid version that's
15 more money to get 12.4 percent fps
well honestly in my opinion i don't
really think it's worth spending the
extra money because in reality you could
just turn down your graphics quality a
little bit to get the same fps i don't
know you guys let me know just comment
down below and you're going to be
entered into that giveaway anyway so let
us know now we are going to return to
some more graphics heavy tests with
final cut pro and some other things like
that but first i want to get into the
cpu processing side with the cinebench
r23 10 minute stress test which is 3d
rendering that uses the cpu so with that
said let's go ahead and start the test
all right guys while this is running i
opened up the power metrics within the
terminal and as you can see we're using
30.4 watts on the 10 core model
basically 30 watts and over here we are
actually using 22
watts and what makes that interesting is
that it's actually using
36
percent more wattage even though it just
has two extra high performance cores so
i wonder if it's actually going to make
it heat up more
yes in fact we can see that the fans
are actually running a little bit louder
and faster here 4 400 rpms compared to
2400 this one the bin model
is running cooler wow look at that 4400
and yes if i get a little bit closer
i can hear the fans on the unbend model
but not this one i can't even hear the
ones on the bin so that's very
interesting and don't worry about fan
noise because by this time over five
minutes into the test the previous intel
models would be screaming full blast on
both of these so this is actually really
really impressive that it's just barely
audible and now that we're almost nine
minutes into the test i want to check
the thermals so we have the bend model
right here the hottest point is on the
keyboard right there that hot spot 44
degrees celsius let's go over to this
one and interestingly
43 degrees celsius between the keyboard
and the display that's because of those
exhaust vents because the fans are
spinning up faster so it's blowing out
that hot air at least trying to so
that's actually really impressive all
right the bin model is almost done and
there we go oh wow that is an
interesting score go ahead and comment
how much you think the performance
difference is below because
wow that's not what i expected we got 12
292 points on the unbin model and 9486
points on the band model that means this
one is 30
faster in the stress test now the fans
did have to ramp up more but you are
getting that extra performance and if
you're just going from the 8 core to the
10 core that's a 200 upgrade so that's
10
more money for 30
real world 100 cpu stress test
performance and i would say that is
definitely worth it at least for
something like this but we are going to
get into some real world tests very soon
and with that said let's go ahead and
get into our xcode benchmark which is
for all of you programmers out there but
before we get started i do want to shout
out our merch this is our apple product
icon t right here we have a bunch of
other stuff for you guys and you can use
the coupon code promo code m1 pro to get
20 off on all of our merch so definitely
do that to help support this channel
thank you guys and let's get into this
and bam they are running on both
machines we want to thank maxim eramenko
for making this benchmark and this
terminal script so it runs really
quickly without having to do a bunch of
extra steps all right we have our scores
here and this is actually different
compared to how the beginning of this
video went it looks like we have 97
seconds for the unbend model in a 108.5
for the bend that is a difference of
only 19
faster for the more expensive model
we're not seeing those 30 improvements
anymore and the reason for that is
because xcode really takes advantage of
the new unified memory architecture and
the extra memory bandwidth so you're
getting both of the advantages with both
of these so i guess cpu isn't making
that big of a difference here but i do
want to mention that 97 seconds is
absolutely insane because the best score
ever registered was 90 seconds with the
insanely expensive 28 core xeon mac pro
so this thing is a beast for a 14 inch
laptop so i guess in the real world both
of these are just so screaming fast that
you don't really have to pay the extra
200
for the unbinned model you're still
gonna get really really great
performance compared to intel chips
alright and here we are running the
logic pro benchmark for all of you music
producers out there and as you can see
the unbid model is running
155 tracks without overloading which is
consistent with the m1 pro 16 inch now
let's run the bend model and we have 115
now interestingly in our previous video
against the macbook air it was able to
do 115 tracks without overloading but it
is now so i don't know why it's doing it
i'm going to turn off a couple of tracks
and see if it can handle look at that
113
it's not handling it let's go down to
110
it should be doing it all right and here
we go i went down to 105 tracks and it
seems to be running just fine so you
should be expecting between 105 to 115
tracks without overloading maybe there's
some kind of background app or something
running but there you go there's a
difference 105 to
155 so you're getting 50 more tracks
that are running on the unbind model
which is actually really impressive and
if you want to know exactly what's going
on within this benchmark just go ahead
and google new logic pro benchmark and
you'll find out exactly what's going on
and what instruments are playing and now
with that said let's move over to adobe
lightroom classic this is for all of you
photo editors out there now just for
editing and doing stuff like that maybe
doing brushes you should be expecting
the same performance as you can see
it actually kind of looks like the
unbend model is switching images
slightly faster so hey that's already
a benefit for that more expensive model
but what i'm really interested in is the
export test so let's go ahead and export
all 50 of these raw 42 megapixel images
now i do want to mention while this is
running that between these two there's
not really going to be that big of a
difference in the real world for editing
on the fly or in real time so i wouldn't
say it's really worth spending the extra
200 because these are just so fast
compared to the old intel models but i'm
interested to see how this export test
goes now the unbid model is almost
finished and the fans are really ramping
up 5700 rpms it's actually almost maxed
out and let's see it's about to finish
there you go it's done dang those fans
are loud and these ones are at 3 400 rpm
and i can just barely hear them all
right the export is done and the unbid
model finished in a minute in 22 seconds
compared to a minute and 45 for the bend
model that is a difference of 28
faster for this more expensive one now
in reality the everyday editing
experience isn't going to really change
when you're actually editing the photos
but for the exports of course you get
the faster 28 difference however the
fans were blaring on this one so it's a
question of do you want the faster
performance with the trade-off of having
a louder machine or do you want the
cheaper one that is more silent i don't
know it's up to you to make that
decision so if you have any comments on
that leave them down below and now
moving on with lightroom out of the way
let's go ahead and move into a gpu test
this is blender this is the party tug
test that you could actually download
from the internet and test it yourself
on your machine and compare to these
scores so this is going to be using the
gpu so let's go ahead and render them
all right there we go and this
difference is hilarious
9.06 seconds for the more expensive
model
9.74 for the bin model there's basically
no difference if you're doing this type
of gpu rendering with blender there is
no reason to go for this unbend 14 inch
now you might want to go for the m1 max
model but not from the bend to the
unbanned and now we're going to switch
it up a little bit with the splash fox
test which you can also download now
this is going to be using the cpu
instead of the gpu so we're gonna see
how much more performance you get going
from eight cores to 10 cores let's begin
and there we go the test is finished now
go ahead and guess the difference
because this is kind of funny the unbend
model is
2.8
faster wow so i guess there's no
difference between the bend and the
unbind and i think the reason for that
is because it's not fully utilizing the
cpu it's not going up to 100 usage it's
staying down so i wonder if there's some
kind of other limit that's not allowing
us to get the full performance but
either way for all you blender renderers
out there you're totally fine with the
less expensive bin model and now moving
on let's go ahead and get into video
editing with final cut pro it's a very
popular app this is one of the reasons
why a lot of people buy macs so our
first test we're gonna do is 4k h.26
video editing now i want to mention that
this is probably the most common codec
for shooting videos in fact all of our
videos on our youtube channel are shot
in 4k
h.264 which is this so let's go ahead
and run an export test to see which
one's faster i've got my timer right
here and let's go ahead and begin we're
over halfway through this test and if
you look at the percentages the progress
they're both neck and neck basically 60
on both of them and the point i want to
make is that neither of the gpus are
getting maxed out even the bin model is
only at 66 percent that's because both
of these share the same video encoders
and this test is limited by the encoders
now we do have some effects we have two
luts in fill grain but that is not
enough to put enough of a stress on the
gpu now if you're loading tons and tons
of effects then maybe there's gonna be a
difference but in reality as you can see
they're both at the same progress the
test is done and both models finish at
the exact same time two minutes in 55
seconds so in reality i don't think it's
worth upgrading to the on bin version
because going from eight course to ten
course is gonna do literally nothing for
video editing and final cut pro because
there are no codecs that really stress
the cpu now that red raw and canon raw
are gpu based the cpu difference makes
no difference and for the gpu as you saw
we're getting the same export speeds for
the most common video codec so don't
upgrade for this kind of stuff and now
let's get into the big guns we are doing
pro res raw but luckily these new m1 pro
and m1 max macbook pros come with pro
res and pro res raw video encoders and
decoders so that means when you're
playing it back there's really no
difference because they're both relying
on those media engines and now i'm going
to be doing a export test let's go ahead
and start it we're going to see if
there's gonna be a difference here what
the gpu difference is but i think it's
gonna be pretty close let's see and
there you go the test is finished and
just as expected there is barely any
difference the unbend model finished in
a minute and four seconds compared to a
minute and seven seconds with the less
expensive bend model so because they're
really relying on those pro res encoders
the 15 gpu core difference isn't really
doing enough to matter so these machines
are basically flying through progress
compared to any other machine so with
that said in those video editing tests
out of the way i would say if you're
using final cut pro or doing video
editing definitely do not upgrade to the
unbind model because they're basically
neck and neck the same relying on those
awesome new encoders all right guys wow
that was a ton of benchmarks so finally
let's answer the original question is it
worth paying more on the 14 inch to get
the unbend m1 pro or should you just
save that money well in reality from all
of our testing i would say that it is
not worth it because even in gaming you
did get an improvement but not by that
much and xcode it was a little bit
faster but it's already crazy fast
compared to intel machines and video
editing basically no difference the
biggest difference we actually saw was
in lightroom where you did get a nice
jump in performance but in reality
you're not spending all the time all day
exporting you're doing the edits in real
time to the photos and between those two
there's not really a difference actually
if i remember correctly there was a
difference the more expensive model was
actually louder because it's using more
wattage so that's an even bigger plus
for that base model so with all of that
said i do not think that most people
should be upgrading to the unbanned
model just save your money and spend it
on something else like an ssd storage
upgrade or you could upgrade the ram
from 16 gigs to 32 gigs and that might
actually give you a real difference and
that is exactly what we're gonna be
testing in our next video and by the
time you're watching right now that
video may already be done so check right
over there and if it is definitely watch
that video and if you're not already
subscribed click the circle above to
enter that giveaway don't forget to
comment down below guys thanks for
watching and we will see you in the next
video
[Music]